hey there welcome to con Brian needs a
friend that's going in oh man I'm I'm
making just little different mouth
noises today I came in hot I think there
are days where I come in hot and today I
am nuclear fueled Conan um had a good
workout this morning oh yep lifted a lot
well thank you very much you don't just
get a body like mine you need to really
abuse
yourself Sona good to see you nice to
see you too you did come in hot cuz we
were laughing and you're like no one can
laugh without me I hear laughter in a
room I'm not in I suspect
fraud you know it's like a company that
couldn't possibly make that it just
doesn't seem right I'm always like what
laughter and I'm not
there this must be some someone's
something just is fundamentally wrong so
I came rushing in here yeah uh and then
I guess Gorly was chuckling everybody I
was just telling them something that you
had said earlier that was so
funny There we go all right well that
makes sense I'm satisfied my name is Joy
killer what laughter I must go crush it
make it about me I just noticed sona's
wedding ring yeah yeah I was just about
to hit on you no uh no I was going to
say it was your hand was out and it was
tilted and it's very nice why a rock I
have my fingers got skinnier so I have
this plastic coil around it and I've had
it there for can't you just go to a
jeweler and they can quickly resize it
well cuz I think I'm going to it's going
to go back up I'm sure I think so I'm
just leaving it there so it's going to
just get bigger eventually the whole
ring is just going to be a plastic coil
I think yeah why don't you just lose
that I'll hold on to the actual diamond
and you can just wear a plastic coil no
you'll get it back at one point I don't
want to do that well anyway I just
noticed it and it's uh it's nice thank
you I don't think I ever looked at it
really before thank you I actually don't
even think I look at you very often oh
that's nice no no I I just I'm just very
so focused on me and what I'm doing
that's clear yeah and so I don't oh
Gorly that's me this is what I look like
oh my God you usually have a mirror in
front of both of us just so you never
have to actually look I think every
employee at uh at Team Coco wear an oval
mirror on their face it's a two-way
mirror so they can see through it but
you just see yourself no I actually am
assisting on a oneway mirror so they
crash into things and have get into
terrible car accidents yeah it's a mess
around here of just broken people are
just smashing into the wall all the time
but I'm happy because I just see me me
me I'm an opera singer warming up me me
me me me you did come in hot you're
singing a lot too yeah I sure amti H
that usually implies like coming hot
you're grumpy you're mad You' got
something to Pro no you came in kind of
just you're just living you're buzzing
you know what I'm happy uh life is good
uh I am happy to be here at the podcast
I'm with some of my favorite people hold
on let me put on my glass
oh I didn't see who was in I'm
sorry no I thought I was with Jeff
Goldblum and the Ghost of Abraham
Lincoln and then it turns out it's
squirly and so I apologize I wish Jeff
Goldwin was here and the Ghost of
Abraham Lincoln he'd be like I'm just
was at the theater what the and I'm
like Gabe you wrote the Gettysburg
address and you just said what the
I know every Christmas season it's the
same thing demands for more podcast
episode comes in and we've got to meet
those demands we got to mail out podcast
we got to get him in the mail well guess
what with stamps.com all you need is a
computer and printer then you're ready
for that Holiday Rush you know what I'm
saying no remember last year when we
were stuffing podcast into envelopes and
licking them and putting on the stamps
it was crazy in here yeah no more not
with stamps.com they even send you a
free scale so you have everything you
need to get started cuz whenever I go to
mail stuff out I'm like where's my scale
well they got the scale ready there for
you now taking care of orders on the go
is even easier with the stamps.com
mobile app if you need a package pickup
you can easily schedule it through your
stamps.com
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart get your business ready
for the holiday Rush get started with
stamps.com today sign up at stamps.com
Conan for a special offer that includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Conan I've told you that uh
sketch I always wanted to write where oh
yeah I think I mentioned on the air yeah
Lincoln is in heaven and he's walking
around and he sees a group having a
really good time and he goes up to the
group cuz they're all laughing real hard
and John wi Booth is at the center and
everyone's Lincoln's like what the
is he doing up here in heaven and
they're like you know what he was really
good to his mom and d and that night
with you was having an off night one off
he was having an off night and Lincoln's
really mad and they're like come on Abe
and and then Booth is like you know I Mr
Lincoln I'm I'm sorry I don't know what
I was thinking but I am a big fan when
he goes to shake Lincoln's hands and
Lincoln swats it out of the way like I'm
not going to shake your hand and then
everyone else Aristotle Gandhi everybody
else is like whoa Abe not
cool I had this idea like 25 years ago
and I never wrote make this happen
because you mentioned it a few times I
feel like for your birthday yeah how
does it end yeah does it have a button
they get into a fight and Booth shoots
Lincoln again oh no and then he goes to
second heaven yeah but everyone says
like you know a you were kind of being a
dick and Abes uh so uh Abe gets sent
down to hell um I don't know I don't
know how it ends but uh this has just
been spitball you've never written it
I've I've talked to talked about it a
lot I have so many sketches in my head
that I never wrote because they just
seemed too weird and arbitrary uh but uh
that one um always amused me I want to
know what something is too weird for you
cuz have you seen some of the you
put on TV uh I'm what a nice way to put
it you know I'm going to make sure if I
ever if I ever get a major award for my
work in comedy I'm going to have Sona
give it to me and she'll do the speech
up here they give the award to Conan
O'Brien after 90 years in comedy is son
messian you know I don't know much about
Conan but have you seen some of this
he did I meant that in a loving way
I'm sure you did in an admiring way I
just I'm I don't like your wedding ring
anymore oh okay yeah okay that'll show
you oh no yeah I think it's poorly
fitted to your finger there that'll show
you